salut je m'appelle Timo Phillip et je viens de
Hyde River Je vis juste au-dessus du
trou toute ma vie Je fais des trucs sur la glace de mer
en travaillant avec la cerise environ quatre
ans maintenant où je ne suis pas au-delà de la glace
de l'autre  rivière de la peste
c'est la station un à chaque fois que je
vérifie environ 15 minutes je vérifie
chacun d'eux tous ceux-ci et ça et la
neige j'arrive ici j'ai le générateur Graaff et le
mets là-dedans et le démarre et j'ai
mesuré un câble sur  les deux par deux par
deux et l'épaisseur de la glace, ils sont toujours
différents même s'ils sont très proches d'
environ trois pieds l'un de l'autre, ils sont toujours
différents.
cette température à
la coque la nuit la percer et la
température sait que la glace à quel point il
fait froid après cela je mesure la neige que
j'admets comme cinq centimètres à chaque
fois 5 centimètres je l'ai mesuré et la
température reste différente tout
le temps j'essaie  utiliser le même trou tout
le temps parce que chaque fois que j'ai des
cheveux, essayez de continuer à l'utiliser même
si quand il y a de la neige qui ronfle,
cela pense que ce poteau ici,
c'est que nous savons qu'il coupe le mauvais
ici, c'est difficile de courir mais c'est  toujours à l'
intérieur, c'est doux, c'est pourquoi nous essayons
de continuer à utiliser la même direction en toute sécurité tout
le temps.
chaque année
comme c'est différent c'est pourquoi je l'aime
bleu
Oh